des citoyens également engagé à
guyancourt où un collectif vient de se
créer décidons ensemble à guyancourt
réuni des habitants pour un objectif de
présenter une liste pour les élections
municipales en 2020 une priorité celle
de la démocratie participative hier une
réunion était organisée sur le thème
bien livre dans mon quartier des rendez
vous qui se tiennent sous forme
d'ateliers pour réfléchir et formuler
des propositions en vue d'un programme
le collectif se laisse jusqu'à septembre
pour le construire avant de constituer
une liste candidate pour le scrutin les
propos sont recueillis par manon varaldo
est une initiative qui est parti de
citoyens citoyennes de la ville souvent
investis en milieu associatif
on avait plutôt dans l'est on va dire
seul en militant dans l'économie sociale
et solidaire
la transition écologique aux médias il
ya beaucoup de questions qui tournent en
démocratie participative comment est-ce
qu'on mettra en oeuvre la démarche avec
la cie participative
parce que je vis en cours à une échelle
particulière donc on n'applique pas de
la même manière suivant les échelles de
vide
ensuite les question c'est comment qu'on
créera le programme comme on réalise
comment pouvoir faire en sorte que tous
les citoyens puissent apporter leur
pierre à l'édifice comment pouvoir me
faire en sorte que chaque chaque idée
puisse être valorisés sur le programme
mais la maire sortante divers-gauche
marie-christine le tarnec n'a elle pas
encore indiqué si elle était ou non
candidate pour ce scrutin en 2020